Ok, here we go-- Solid, Liquid, Gas,
Supersolid, superfluid
Or Bose-Einstein Condensate.
That one is super.
cool.
Plus, Plasma
But we haven’t even gotten started.
We truly live in the future.
You ready, T?
Scientists have created, yet another state
of matter!
YAY!
It’s called a supersolid.
And while it sounds like a solid.
It’s… well.
It’s not.
A supersolid is basically a superfluid that
got it’s crap together.
Right, and by crap you mean molecules.
Precisely.
The researchers who created this new state
of matter took a Bose-Einstein Condensate,
made of sodium gas, and used lasers to cool
it to near absolute zero.
The atoms are moving extremely slowly.
A BEC is a special phase of matter created
in 2001 winning researchers the Nobel Prize
for Physics.
Once cooled to a BEC, the sodium flowed with
zero friction.
It’s like a Super.
Fluid.
A superfluid.
Which is awesome.
This BEC was also superconductive, meaning
its electrons moved through it with zero resistance.
There are numerous scientific benefits to
these two conditions, but we’re not here
to talk about that.
In this case, the scientists kept cooling
that sodium and at some point, it arranged
into a non-crystalline “solid!”
The scientists called it a superfluid flow
with “long-range spatial periodicity of
[a] solid.”
Those are some fancy science words.
Essentially, think of it like a coffee cup
filled with a frictionless, superconducting,
gel that if you could stir would never stop
going around.
Delicious.
The “fluid” didn’t suddenly become hard,
instead, it’s not exactly solid -- think
like… gel.
It’s a fluid but it behaves like a solid.
They’ve still got a lot to learn about these
fluids / solids, but according to their paper,
their supersolid [quote] “establishes a
system with continuous symmetry-breaking properties,
associated collective excitations and superfluid
behaviour.”
Let’s break that down.
Superfluid behavior you get… frictionless
superconductor
Collective excitations is a fancy way to say
quasiparticles.
Quasiparticles are a group of particles that
behave as if they’re one because their parts
are interacting somehow.
And then there’s symmetry-breaking.
That’s also describing particle movement,
normally in quantum mechanics symmetry is
a big deal.
Breaking it?
A bigger deal.
At the moment, it continues the old saying
-- the closer you look the stranger things
get.
But c’mon, do we have six states of matter
now?
Actually, no.
We don’t.
We have way more.
The states of matter solid, liquid, and gas
that you’ve been living with your whole
life were never all there were.
It’s kind of like when you’re learning
math.
First you’re taught numbers, then they tell
you there are infinite numbers.
Then (as if they’re just messing with you)
they tell you there are infinite negative
numbers too.
And then you find out there are irrational
numbers, and imaginary numbers.
And you can do calculations with infinites
and embed equations into each other and … yah.
Matter is like that.
So yes, solid, liquid, gas and plasma exist
-- and it’s really about molecular arrangement.
Solids are interacting heavily, liquids are
loosey goosey, and gases are just barely interacting
while Plasma is “free” it can do anything.
But on top of those four, there are several
more!
Cold ones like the Bose-Einstein Condensate
and Supersolid and hot ones like electron-degenerate
matter (free particles found in white dwarf
stars) or the theorized stranger matter (possibly
found in neutron stars).
Plus, of course, time crystals.
Which have low-energy states and weird effects
across time symmetry.
We should just do a whole video about states
of matter, right?
Bottom line, we have a new state of matter!
YAY!
But we don’t now have six or seven, we have
at least a dozen, they’re just more… out
there, experimental, laboratory-only or extreme
kinds of matter!
Our universe is awesome.
Boom de-yadda.
Look everyone, if you want to know more about
states of matter, watch this video about Time
Crystals.
It will give you a nice headache, or maybe
it already has.
Do you have an itch for a science answer?
That’s why we’re here.
Tell us in the comments...